If you go to Hong Kong, you should not miss the chance to visit Macau.
It is very close to Hong Kong, but you will have a very different atmosphere there.
Because the Portuguese once ruled Macao,...
...you can still find Catholic churches and many historical remains in Portuguese styles.
However, of particular interest is the Venetian these days.
Even if you don't gamble, you will be blown away by this imposing development.
It is absolutely stunning!
The 40-floor luxury hotel tower has 2,900 suites, a 550,000 square foot casino floor,...
...one million square feet of shopping,...
...and a 1,800-seat theater that runs an original Cirque du Soleil production.
Visitors wonder about how it was possible to construct such a colossus.
It is huge, and there are masses to do!
You will be amazed about the effort that must have gone into designing a real Venice...
...with a grand canal, gondolas, and the intricate dome ceiling paintings.